Boston native Joey dord has recorded a point in
each of his last seven starts the ball dropped
at midnight now the P drops outoors back out
to the point for Hy and then across J by for
trano great save through some traffic St it's shot
right on and Joey dord SPS out in the blue paint
golden I looking to tie it Mel unable to get it
past the court oh he's Rob what the court on Q
wow big save by Joey dord Michael can't believe
it with the face off coming back into the Vegas
zone less than 6 seconds I think we're safe to
point out Kenny Kenny Kenny K 6 seconds K there
have been four shut outs Kenny you called the
penalty earlier today there have four shutouts
in outdoor I think he's safe he's safe but none
in a Winter Classic that's it Bo keep coming off
the top turn Buck there you go going to cord
with the first Winter Classic shutout listen
during the game and especially later on the
great crowd here started saying Joey Joey Joey
what can you say about that young golender
Joey dord all he's been through to get to
the NHL and the performance on this big stage
yeah he's been great for us lately uh he's so
confident back there uh it's it's it's amazing
and uh you deserve every bit of the Joey Joey
Joey let's go here we go with Joey great show
Seattle your father goalie goalie coach um what
do you think this means for your family you
know it just kind of brings into perspective
um you know how special it all is and just to
have him here tonight um you know we'll never
forget today that's awesome we can help you carry
this out because you are the first ever winner of
Jo the Winter Classic MVP you playing
outside need some h and you get the
trophy right here MVP let's he one more
time Joe cour thank you guys so much